immigrants we get the job done or so the
song goes so we all know that when it
comes to labor the United States loves
immigrants and one of the most unique
stories of American immigration and
labor actually comes from the
Philippines in particular it's the story
of Filipino women who became nurses
throughout the country's hospitals hey
guys I'm sana this is AJ plus and this
Sunday I want to talk a bit about why
there are so many Filipino nurses in the
United States and what that says about
the history of Filipino Americans and
Filipino labor okay so you might be
saying so now the u.s. has a lot of
Filipino nurses yep here's what's up
back into other 15 a foreign-born
filipinos made up the fourth largest
group of immigrants in the country and
the majority of Filipinos are in
California where they make up 20% of the
nursing force which is impressive when
you consider that they only make up
about 4% of the state's population now
it's easy to think of the Philippines as
all the way over there and the United
States right over here
but dr. Katherine sneeze a joy who wrote
the book Empire of Care says that
imagining Filipinos as simply foreigners
actually erases a history between the
countries
Filipinos and Tiffany certain groups of
Filipino immigrant workers like in the
grand nurses are not foreigners and the
way we tend to think that foreigners
they actually have historical
interactions with American and that
interaction begins like so many other
immigrant interactions with colonization
the Spanish colonized and ruled the
archipelago we now call the Republic of
the Philippines for a few centuries in
1898 the Americans and the Spanish went
to war and it ended with the signing of
the Treaty of Paris as a result the
Americans got a lot of territories from
the Spanish one of which was the
Philippines but the people of the
islands didn't welcome the Americans
they wanted their independence not more
colonizers that resistance led to the
three-year long Philippines American War
from 1899 to 1902 and it was fought
between US forces and Filipino
nationalists and it was a brutal war for
Filipinos it killed 20,000 combatants
and two
hundred thousand civilians as a result
of the violence diseases like cholera
and malaria and even famine when the war
ended the Philippines came under the
colonial control of the United States
and that's when the story of the
Filipino nurses begins like in its other
colonies the United States began the
Americanization of the islands after
setting up a government in the
Philippines
you also had American colonial officials
going to the Philippines and exposing
Filipinos to American culture to the
English language to Americanized
education and this kind of training
influenced so many different groups of
Filipinos to dream about the US and to
desire to migrate their American health
workers in the Philippines needed locals
to deal with the health issues of
Filipinos because malaria and cholera
had killed so many during the war but
they didn't find any nurses trained the
way the Americans had been trained and
so they began recruiting Filipino women
to work as what were called volunteer
auxiliary and contract nurses around the
same time in 1903 President William Taft
passed a law that allowed and funded
certain Filipino students to study in
American colleges and this led to the
first wave of Filipino nurses coming to
the United States and it also led to a
lot of the nurses staying
they even established their presence
with organizations like the Philippine
Nurses Association of New York and the
waves of Filipino nurse migration
continued throughout the 20th century
especially as the United States opened
up its borders a bit more during World
War two more Filipino nurses were
trained to serve in the US military and
during the same time the Philippines
came under Japanese occupation after the
war ended the United States granted the
territory independence in 1946 and two
years later the State Department
introduced the exchange visitor program
a little something created to push back
against Soviet influence you know bring
more people into the United States and
show them what the capitalist good life
is actually all about because of the
decades-long colonial relationship and
education and English language the
Philippines became a model country for
the program and the nurses led the way
the program was so successful that it
actually encouraged more Filipinos to go
into nursing the number of nurses in the
Philippines jumped over 700 percent from
7,000 in 1948 to over 57,000 in 1953 the
program also encouraged
building of more nursing schools in the
Philippines back in 1940 there were only
10 and today 429 that program in
addition to the 1965 Immigration Act
opened up the borders even more for
educated Filipinos and so by 1973 we end
up seeing over 12,000 Filipino nurses
immigrated to the United States but I
gotta mention this it wasn't just
because of American immigration policies
that so many Filipinos were migrating to
the u.s. in the 1970s with President
Ferdinand Marcos who ruled under martial
law a policy of labor export was
introduced the whole idea behind the
export of labor was that Filipinos would
travel abroad on war contracts make
money send it back home and thus help a
struggling economy the government even
created an agency that directly provided
migrant labour to foreign governments
and companies that policy pretty much
made the Philippines one of the top
exporters of labor I mean check this
about 10% of all Filipinos are foreign
workers that's around 10 million people
in around 170 different countries and
did the policy of exporting labor
actually worked for the economy well for
decades the Philippines has been one of
the top five recipients of money
transfers for migrant labor
shoutout to Western Union not sponsored
take for instance how in 2015 over three
million Filipinos left the country to
work abroad they sent back twenty-eight
point five billion dollars which made up
about a tenth of the Philippines total
GDP so exported labor is a big deal for
the Philippines and it really does get
to the heart of the Filipino immigrant
experience whether in a country like
Saudi Arabia or in the United States and
it's equally important to note that
despite the so-called success of the
export of Filipino labor it's come with
a lot of sacrifice struggle and
vulnerability
take for example Filipino nurses here in
the United States who are professionals
but still face discrimination the
vulnerability of being immigrant nurses
can also be connected to being exploited
by being assigned sometimes the most
undesirable kinds of work on the nursing
floor or being assigned on the most
undesirable ship unfortunately they are
not the kind of challenges we
think about in the United States that
these women would have because they are
professional immigrant workers but even
though exported or imported labor is
central to Filipino migration especially
to the United States that's not the only
part of the Filipino immigrant
experience in the United States
Filipinos both citizens and immigrants
have used their experiences to fight for
workers rights in fact one of the
biggest labor movements in the United
States was sparked by Filipino laborers
in 1965 Filipino grape farm workers in
Delano California went on strike against
poor working conditions and low wages
farm workers across the country joined
in on the strike which eventually led to
an international boycott of grapes the
five-year strike ended with a major win
for the farmworkers they got union
contracts that protected them
so Filipinos immigrants and citizens
have been and remained a central part of
the US as social fabric they've not only
provided labor in industries that needed
it the most but at times have also
protected it so we just covered Filipino
nurses in the United States and we've
also talked in the past about Indian
Americans in the motel industry what are
some other communities immigrant
communities that you want us to cover
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
come back next Sunday when we come at
you with another great video